[Musique]
tous
entretien avec la maire de chanteloup
les vignes une mère au coeur de la ville
catherine arnould
[Musique]
la légende urbaine dit que jean-louis
borloo prend conscience de l'urgence
lorsqu'il vient ici lorsqu'il rencontre
pierre cardo et découlera de cette
rencontre ce qu'on appelait le plan
borloo
je suis arrivé à
un soir de novembre
2002 je crois
j'adore cardo et chez elle va on a fait
le quartier on sait mais je m'échappe
mais j'en peux plus j'ai l'impression de
rêver c'est que ça se dégrade que ça
s'aggrave puis on va à sa mairie et au
moment de monter jeudi mais comment tu
qu il dit mais j'ai pas de moyens jean
louis puis avait deux ampoules une
dénudées allumé et l'autre pas lui mais
j'ai pas les moyens de changer lempaut
bonjour catherine r2 est la mère de deux
jours 12 avec vice-présidente socialiste
du conseil départemental
elle marche léopold là maintenant
on est toujours ville pauvre mais les
ampoules marche les six mois tout les
habitants vous diront pas tout et là
c'est une légende urbaine ou pas que au
fond l'idée de la politique de la ville
et le plan borloo séné à chanteloup
alors oui jean louis borloo et ça va il
ya toujours dit attaché au territoire de
champclos oui c'est sans doute les nez
ici pour une première raison c'est que
on était quand même à la fois un symbole
et un exemple de cette de cet urbanisme
gigantesque pas du tout implanté sur le
territoire qui était arrivé comme ça
comme un champignon et mais par contre
la ville était resté à l'échelle humaine
et c'est ce qui d'ailleurs danser dans
l'évolution de cette ville a fait ses
difficultés au départ mes fesses sans
doute une partie de ses réussites ses
l'échelle humaine c'est une ville de
2000 habitants qui est passé de 8000 à
11000 de 11000 à 8000 voilà qui revient
vers 11000 met donc c'est une échelle
qui est une échelle grand village
c'est vrai que c'est un peu différent
des autres morville de la politique de
la ville et je pense que jean louis
borloo a d'autant plus facilement même
s'ils y étaient spontanément très près a
plus facilement vu ce qu'on pouvait
faire ici c'est qu'en fait la taille de
la ville permettent si on y met des
moyens importants et 6 ans et si tout le
monde se met en même temps et des choses
qui peuvent durablement changé le
territoire c'est beaucoup moins vrai
dans des villes de 50 mille cent mille
habitants effectivement vous où les eaux
libres les problèmes soient beaucoup
plus enkystés le problème est prêt je ne
sais pas
c'est que tout est concentré on nous
sommes dans le quartier de la noé un ici
et toute la politique de la ville elle
est concentrée dans ce quartier c'est ça
c'est c'est un seul quartier qui est un
quartier dé de logement social exclusif
comme tous les comme tous ces quartiers
de la grande vallée de la seine dont on
vous a raconté toute l'histoire c'est
aussi des quartiers du logement social
avec les populations les plus fragiles
puisque vous savez dans le logement
social on a on a quelques niveaux et
nous on a dans tous les sens combien la
ville de la vallée de la seine alors
donc on a on a eu alors on a eu jusqu'à
82 % de logement social quand quand
pierre cardo était maire
et puis après on est passé on est resté
très longtemps entre 82 et 75 et
actuellement on est à 44
vous avez des convictions axa assez
forte sur la question de la politique de
la ville justement vous avez fait partie
de la commission borloo et vous parliez
de ces mesures qui sont éparpillés et
alors que vous dites justement que il
faut à la fois la question de
l'éducation la formation la rénovation
urbaine etc c'est aujourd'hui quand vous
voyez la manière dont ce plan est
utilisée qu est-ce que vous qu'est ce
que vous en dites alors vous avez vu que
ce plan avait été rejeté dans un premier
temps mais quelques me jeter bas oui
effectivement on la vit ensemble
quelques mesures et pas des moindres ont
d'ailleurs ont été reprises mais ont été
reprises les unes derrière les autres
sans vision globale il s'en va là sans
cohésion dans la dent dans la volonté
politique alors des mesures très
important de la cité éducative
heureusement qu'elles sont sorties et
tous ceux qui n'avaient pas travaillé
dans le club renommé qui ont bénéficié
de ces sites éducatifs disent bien que
celle pratiquement l'alpha et l'oméga de
la nouvelle façon d'orienter et de
travail et l'éducation dans nos
quartiers à la limite je me demande si
ça voudrait pas pour toute la france
mais en attendant sur nos territoires le
principe de dire on nous sommes tous
acteurs de l'éducation c'est à dire que
nous avons tous une part quelle que soit
notre rôle dans une ville nous avons
tous une part il faut que nous fassions
en partenariat en bonne symbiose et
surtout qu'on est comme seul objectif la
réussite de l'enfant quel que soit et
sans qu on est prêts
prédéterminé sa réussite parce que là
réussissent à s'appuie sur ses propres
compétences et donc l'enfant la réussite
qu'on lui permettra d'avoir mais sa
réussite ne sera pas celle du voisin il
sera pas celle qu'on a mis en tant
qu'adulte en temps avec et qu'on après
des prêts décidés à c'est ça le
principal et je trouve qu'ici en plus
tous les acteurs se sont vraiment
mobilisés pour dire on travaillait
ensemble pour la réussite de l'enfant
chacun avec son savoir faire mais on pas
s'appuyant sur d'abord la compétence de
l'enfant et vous avez mêler les deux
puisque il ya le côté scolaire avec la
cité éducative mais le côté urbain
puisque tout tout tout tout est
construit ensemble tous ensemble ouais
alors ça c'est assez exceptionnel
exceptionnel c
oui mais ça c'est super important
d'abord parce que ce territoire cette
école et tout ça avait besoin
effectivement qu'on ait un nouveau
regard sur elle et le nouveau regard ça
se fait aussi sur un nouvel urbanisme
avec un nouvel urbanisme et c'est
d'autant plus important qu'en fait on
construit les lieux qui sont une cité
éducative qui inclura maternelles
primaires centres de loisirs une
médiathèque la maison des parents la
maison des familles le collège
la restauration pour tous ont il a été
construit par les propres acteurs
c'est-à-dire que ils ont travaillé
pendant accompagné pendant deux ans
environ pour petit à petit posé les
pions pour que ce qu'est ce qu'on
définit comme lieu de travail en commun
soit vraiment ce qu'ils ont voulu est-ce
qu'il correspond à ce qu'ils ont
fabriqué ensemble comme histoire donc
c'est comment comment on travaille
ensemble père éducatif et et moi
enseignante dans un même lieu en étant
chacun à la fois chez soi chez l'autre
mais toujours l'enfant chez lui et donc
en fait ils ont fabriqué ils ont mis
deux ans à fabriquer ce cahier des
charges pour fabriquer le lieu à lieu
qui est quand même assez énorme et qui
correspondra en fait à leur action
quotidien à leur fonctionnement
quotidien et l'architecte plier
la difficulté a été toute la difficulté
lors la difficulté ça a été d'abord
d'accompagner toutes ces bonnes volontés
pour vraiment travailler pour faire le
travail en commun et que et qu'on soit
tous d'accord après que ce travail est
vraiment en commun qui en a pas une
institution ce qu'on est quand même
entre entre institutions une institution
il ya voilà s'installe plus que l'autre
conçois mais c'est aussi c'est aussi
l'avantagé de ces d'avoir fait un
concours d'architecte ou l'aude
l'architecte savait déjà que sa première
sa proposition qui serait retenu serait
une proposition évolutive donc il a été
retenu en début 2020 et depuis 2000 va y
continuer à élaborer son projet à faire
avancer son projet en fonction du
travail qui est fait par les différentes
équipes et
voilà on est en train de le poser le
projet là et maintenant on a commencé ce
travail là début 2019 et on le pose me
2022 et avec et avec une petite
particularité à chanteloup alors ça on
l'avait on a sauté sur l'occasion parce
qu'on n'avait pas prévu on s'était dit
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait un
travail en un endroit où les enfants
sont encore présents on l'avait déjà
vécu ça c'est super compliqué pour les
enseignants pour les enfants c'est quand
même beaucoup de bouleversements de
démolir à droite reconstruire à gauche
et hussein on s'est dit on fait table
rase et on trouve un lieu et on fabrique
a lieu un lieu intermédiaire qui va
durer deux à trois ans où ça sera à la
fois le lieu de ce que j'appelle le
brouillon mais équipe en or de ça mais
le brouillon c'est pas c'est pas un
mauvais terme c'est de dire eh bien tout
ce qu'on a pensé depuis deux ans et demi
on va là on va le mettre en application
la ce qu'on appelle la cité champeau qui
est pas très loin qu'on a construit
spécialement pour ça et pendant ce temps
là on va élaborer complètement ce qu'on
remettra dans la cité éducative
justement pour rester
sur la question de l' architecture
justement qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous tirer comme leçon de ce qui a été
fait du passé et les erreurs à ne plus
reproduire en matière de l'architecturé
alors si on pouvait ne plus revenir
d'erreur sera la meilleure jamais je
suis jamais elle complètement convaincu
non c'est vrai que ici les erreurs sont
flagrantes 1
ne pas penser enfin penser une ville
sans penser la vie de l'habitant parce
que c'était ça ça a été ça a été une
ville une ville idéale selon
selon un architecte mila diou mais cette
ville idéale a été idéal était idéal
pour le moment où il a construit or on
est obligé de se projeter dans 10 ans 20
ans 30 ans c'est à dire comment évolue
une population que données économiques
restent peu stable et
aimeriez clic en plus une ville sa vie
et donc comment penser l'urbanisme de
demain en pensant que ça va vivre ça
doit s'inclure alors moi demande par
exemple à à tout ce qu'on a fait on a
beaucoup construit ce que les habitants
en fait il ya quinze ans ils voulaient
tous partir de champion voie de la cité
et demande de logements étaient en
dehors de chanteloup maintenant il y en
a que deux ou trois qui veulent partir
ils tous restés assez dans des endroits
différents soit dans le hlm et dans un
appartement plus grand soin devenir
propriétaire soit donc en fait ils sont
ils sont demandeurs de rester dans ce
qui a fait leur vie parce qu'ils y ont
pris leur part mais il faut se il faut à
mon avis construire c'est pas le seul
élément mais il faut à mon avis
construire comme si ça s'était fait au
fil du temps et n'ont pas amené un geste
architectural un a priori
la priory architectural l'architecte il
a oui mais nous on doit avoir on doit
avoir le son on doit avoir lieu en fin
le sentiment qu'il faut que ça vive pour
les habitants d'aujourd'hui les
habitants de demain les habitants
d'après de masse dire que quand la
population évolue comment évolue le lieu
est donc tout ce qu'on a fait construire
là depuis quinze ans et il faut que ça
soit ça s'intègre dans avec les nouveaux
usages avec les nouveaux palais nouveau
public avec alors on gagne jamais
complètement mais ebi sur tout et
surtout c'est fini à mon avis ce temps
dieu on impose une densité énorme dans
un territoire qui va devoir l'absorber
avec difficulté on fait toujours quelque
chose a encore à l'échelle humaine
jamais plus de 50 60 logements de façon
à ce que les habitants ne soient pas
considérés comme des étrangers dans un
territoire mais s'intègre très vite et
prennent leur part dans l'évolution de
ce territoire
il ya beaucoup
d'expérience d'expérimentation qui sont
faites de petits des quartiers de la
ville par les maires et vous avez lancé
avec d'autres mères d'ailleurs le
conseil national des solutions où on sûr
qu'il ya quelque chose qui est en train
de changer c'est à dire que pendant
longtemps les maires des dvd quartiers
de la politique de la ville était un peu
considérée par l'état comme des
emmerdeurs qui venait demander qui
venait quémander
l'impression que c'est en train de
changer et qu'on est en train de
s'apercevoir qu'ils ont fait des choses
qu'ils ont fait des expérimentations des
choses qui ont marché au kivu groupe a
marché mais on peut choisir et que ce
sont les maires qui influence
aujourd'hui la la politique de l'état ça
serait bon
c'est pourri on aimerait que ça c'est
comme ça oui on est un certain nombre de
maires qui nous connaissons depuis
longtemps qui viennent de la france
entière de tout parti politique et qui
ont en commun voilà d'avoir des
quartiers et d'avoir eu des politiques
de proximité d'avoir d'avoir porté les
politiques des habitants plus que plus
que imposer des politiques
institutionnels et on s'est aperçu et on
en parle très souvent on s'est aperçu
qu'en fait si nos quartiers elle est
plutôt un peu mieux ou s'il y avait des
choses formidables qui se faisait
c'était le fait de l'énergie du
territoire de l'énergie des habitants et
qui avait plein de solutions locales qui
avaient comme qui avait comme à venir
d'être déclinée nationalement alors on
l'a vu petit à petit mais mais en fait
on est tellement le nez du guidon qu' il
faut se retourner 21 en arrière pour
s'apercevoir qu'en fait c'est dans les
quartiers que telle chose a commencé
telle chose a commencé donc on est parti
de ce principe là en disant des
solutions des problèmes locaux tout le
monde les connaît des solutions lequel
nous les avons souvent elles sont elles
sont ignorés ou elles ne sont connus que
du tir et du tirailleur qu'il fait est
alors qu'elles ont la possibilité d'être
d'être pansées d'une façon plus
nationale et puis surtout elles ont la
possibilité de ne plus être cette
politique ascendante descendante d'un an
qui dit il faut faire ça et en fait ça
ne s'applique pas aux quartiers nous
l'idée c'est vraiment il ya des
solutions locales ces solutions locales
on les évalue localement on s'aperçoit
qu'elles ont une
vraie une vraie portée positive et donc
on se pose la question savoir si elles
peuvent pas décliner ailleurs ça c'est
d'abord ça rend les gens extrêmement
fiers de porter des solutions locales
extrêmement mobilisé puis en plus qui
est un truc qu'on sait très bien faire
ce qu'on nous l'a appris depuis 30 ans
est évaluée on nous demande toujours de
nous évaluer nous vous le faites comme
si les maires de la politique de la
ville était et est moins sérieux que les
maires comme les maires de vie normale
donc nous on demande toujours de nous
évaluer mais auquel on s'est valu tout
le temps parce qu'en fait à chaque fois
qu'on fait des petits pas il faut
surtout pas en avoir fait 3 et
s'apercevoir que ça va pas il faut
s'arrêter au 1er faut évaluer fort faut
il faut revoir le parcours et donc on a
et on a cette politique d'évaluation
permanente elle est dans nos gènes il ya
comme ça que ça peut marcher d'ailleurs
non mais c'est vous d'ailleurs vous vous
dites quelque chose de fondamental là
dessus ou dit que les territoires ne
sont pas un poids pour le pays mais des
opportunités
sortie mais je dois d'abord parce qu'on
veut tous que ça qu'on sorte de cette
description de nos quartiers qui n'est
qu'une description des problématiques
alors qu'en fait nous avons des
quartiers jaune nous avons des quartiers
qui sont extrêmement qui ont une énergie
d'enfer alors c'est un peu normal
l'énergie un l'énergie c'est quand on
doit quand rien n'est simple et qu'on
doit trouver seul mais généralement à
plusieurs une façon de sortir d'une
problématique donc ça donne une énergie
l'enfer et ça se voit sur nos quartiers
c'est le nombre de jeunes qui veulent
créer leur entreprise
le nombre d'associations qui créent des
dispositifs nouveaux voilà le nombre de
nombre d'habitants qui qui viennent se
mobiliser pour des causes alors que l'or
leurs vies ne le prédestinait pas semblé
il ya une énergie d'enfer il ya nous
sommes des quartiers jeunes une énergie
d'en faire des savoir-faire des micros
savoir faire locaux qui on arrive à
décliner et donc en fait si on met tout
ça bout à bout mais on s'aperçoit que
cette fois la france de demain c'est la
france de sa jeunesse et la france de
l'énergie c'est la france du savoir
faire nous avons tous assurent nos
quartiers dire ce que dit un peu jean
louis borloo c'est par ces quartiers
qu'on va arriver à faire une nation
c'est ça qui c'est ça qui parce que ce
qui se passe de bien dans ses critiques
c'est ça oui parce qu'en plus ces
quartiers avec les habitants les
habitants de ces quartiers là aussi une
particularité c'est qu'il ne regarde il
regarde très peu en arrière il regarde
toujours en avant ils pensent leur
avenir plus que penser leur passé c'est
aussi le fait que le passé cours sur nos
quartiers le passé a été compliqué sur
nos quartiers donc en fait il se
projette vers l'avenir mais c'est
peut-être un peu ça qu'on demande à la
nation c'est te projeter vers l'avenir
ou tout simplement d'être réaliste je
crois qu'ils sont pragmatiques à un
moment donné je crois que les quartiers
aujourd'hui sont devenus pragmatiques
donc quand on peut pas on fait
rafal sonik était le préfet à l'égalité
des chances et donc on a interviewé au
début de cette émission
disait la politique de la ville ça
marche ça m'a notamment l'éducation ça
marche bien la cité éducative il ya
peut-être encore un problème concernant
l'emploi et l'insertion
oui alors je m'en aille à un problème
oui parce que ce qu'on fait dans le
domaine de l'éducation n'a pas encore
porté ses fruits ce sont des saisons des
dispositifs aidés des avancées trop
raide il faut il faut au moins 15 ans
pour voir si ça va porter ses fruits
elle portera mais oui on a des vrais
problèmes de formation
chez les jeunes on a des vrais problèmes
dans vie collectifs m en fait ce qu'on
monte à depuis quelques années dans
beaucoup de nos territoires c'est donner
aux jeunes
la possibilité d'arrêter de s'interdire
parce qu'en fait il ya eu pendant très
très longtemps vous le disiez tout à
l'heure il ya eu pendant très très
longtemps des interdictions programmé
quoi l'avenir est l avenir était
programmé sur ces jeunes sur certains
métiers sur certaines formations le
plafond nouvel an et le plafond de verre
or or en fait on a honte je crois que
d'abord leur redonner leur liberté leur
liberté d'ores et leur liberté d'arrêter
de s'interdire et puis après c'est à la
société d accompagner quand ils ont le
courage d'arrêter s'interdire et ça
c'est ça aussi donc la formation elle
est basée là-dessus ici on a par exemple
je sais pas si vous en parlerez mais
depuis trail depuis pas mal de temps un
dispositif avec l'essec qui s'appelle
une grande école pourquoi pas moi mais
c'est vraiment le dispositif phare qui
est vraiment vous vous êtes vous ne vous
interdisez pas et pattes parce que vous
avez le courage et l'envié nous on se
doit de vous accompagner mais alors
justement mais est ce que vous n'avez
pas l'impression qu'on fait un pas en
avant on en fait disent en arrière parce
que
cette discussion on l'a eue sur
moi qui suis pas mal engagées sur ces
sujets depuis une vingtaine d'années en
2006-2007 après la révolte des banlieues
il ya eu tout un mouvement qui est né de
sa et avec à la conclusion la fameuse
filière égalité des chances qui visait à
gt parrain de la chaire égalité des
chances des deux films par exemple où
justement l'objectif c'était de casser
cette 7e place ce plafond de verre est
d'emmener des jeunes qui jamais n'aurait
pensé aller dans ses grandes écoles
y aller mais j'ai l'impression qu'on
fait on va faire un pas quand il ya un
autre gouvernement qui arrive derrière
on recule quand il ya d'autres qui
prennent le pouvoir on reprend peut-être
un tout petit peu parfois et mais c'est
pas une question de politique générale
et après ça au niveau de la formation
vous parle quand vous parlez de la
formation est ce que on n'a pas de
dévaloriser justement la formation
contrairement à des pays comme
l'allemagne qui ont toujours valoriser
la formation et qui met en avant parce
qu'on a l'impression que ce sont des
filières de garage
lorsqu'on va en formation qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour cela qu'il ya
d'encore plus absolument est là bas
c'est là justement que le fait de verser
la tendance et d'arrêter de lutter
contre l'échec scolaire cas quand même
été les programmes réguliers depuis 20
ans on arrêtait de on essayait d'arrêter
l'échec scolaire je pense qu'il faut
complètement inversé et on est en
accompagnement de la réussite et quand
on accompagne la réussite en fonction de
la compétence de l'enfant on a plus de
problème de savoir si une formation et
qualifiantes par qualifiant dit tout ça
on accompagne en accompagne l'enfant
fonction de sa propre compétence et nous
on a pas à dire ce que sera son avenir
son avenir on doit le porter on doit
l'accompagner et et dans ces cas là on a
plus dire archi dans les formations la
formation a fallu aller dans une
formation pour passer ainsi ap ou aller
dans une grande école c'est la même
qualité de réussite c'est simplement ça
que ça accompagne la volonté et l'envié
de l'enfant c'est complètement différent
mais il ya quand même un changement de
paradigme ne sait dire que jusque
jusqu'à n'y a pas très longtemps les
écoles dans ces quartiers s'étaient pas
forcément les meilleurs les
établissements scolaires ma petit même
si des signaux sociaux d'aidé beaucoup
là c'est l'excellence qui vient dans ces
quartiers avec la cité éducative
notamment celles exercées cathy mais
l'excellence en fait elle s'appuie sur
les enfants qui sont là elles ne créent
pas une excellente
sortie de nulle part elle s'appuie sur
les compétences des enfants qui sont là
elle s'appuie sur la volonté des parents
d'accompagner moi je suis stupéfaite
depuis c'est fini le temps enfin il ya
en tout cas ici c'est fini la période de
l'enfant du parent qui abandonne c'est
fini vous demander aux enseignants
demandé au principal de collège vous
verrez la qualité du suivi et le
volontarisme des parents maintenant
pourquoi parce que ils ont quand même
été exclu très longtemps et ils ont été
exclus pour plein de raisons parce que
parce que leur parcours avait été
chaotique même pour eux mêmes et puis
parce que spontanément on ne considérait
pas comme un qu'aux éducateurs du
bâtiment ils sont co est éducateur banon
et qu'ils existent dans cette danse est
dans cette éducation fait par tous et
ben en fait ils jouent complètement le
rôle et je peux vous assurer qu'ils sont
sacrément présent mais est en même temps
on a on a quand même un déficit souvent
dans ces quartiers et justement c'est
peut-être là où les les structures comme
les mairies ou les associations peuvent
faire un un vrai boulot c'est sur la
question de la culture générale souvent
dans ces quartiers les gens qui sont
issus de ces quartiers quand il arrive
par exemple dans les grandes écoles les
la première année par exemple elle va
consister à avoir des des mentors qui
vont les accompagner sur la question de
la culture générale comment on peut
remédier à ça aujourd'hui parce que
c'est le fondement de 2,2 de cet échec
entre guillemets 1
là dessus d'abord parce que la culture
générale c'est l'ouverture des yeux
surtout sur la vie sur sur l'art sur la
géographie sur la musique voilà la
culture générale c'est ça hein c'est
ouvrir c'est juste donc d'abord leur
apprendre à ouvrir les yeux sur autre
chose que ce qui est ce qui a été lent
ce qui est leur quotidien
effectivement faut aller chercher
ailleurs faut aller chercher ailleurs
des partenariats et faut qu' il faut que
ces partenariats là tu sois sûr que ici
aussi il ya une richesse qui sera la
culture de demain parce que c'est ça
aussi c'est à la falloir ouvrir les yeux
mais il faut qu'il participe à la
culture de demain celles qui participent
à l'art de mag on a on a par exemple un
partenariat avec le théâtre montansier
on a un partenariat avec l'opéra comique
et mais c'est eux qui viennent pour
accompagner les des tranches d'âge voilà
enfin en faisant en fait de la culture
en faisant une de la culture kid à la
fois la culture un peu ancestrale mais
cultures adaptées à ce qu'est ce qu'est
la france en 2022 ce qu'il affronte de
nos quartiers aussi en 2022 et en fait
ce partenariat est extrêmement riche
vous verriez les gamins au théâtre
montansier alors évidemment nos loulous
convoyés en visio une z c'est versailles
ici
parce qu'ils n'oublient pas ce qu'ils
occupent du dal télévision avait de la
lumière mais bien sûr il y avait la
foule mais c'est génial combien plus les
gens du théâtre montansier était super
fier de l'attention des gamins et
combien les gamins étaient très était
super fier de l'attention qu'on leur
portait enfin gilles c'est un truc
gagnant gagnant ça donc effectivement la
culture donc dans une dans la politique
de la ville culture et sport savez le
sport aussi absolument partie sport
comme facteur d'intégration
capacité d'évoluer de grandir de vivre
comme les autres français il ya une
question du tout parlé tout à l'heure
avec romain c'est bien c'est celle de
l'image quand même des quartiers elle
reste très très présente en fait c'est
ça le plus compliqué et je pense que
c'est de ça aussi qu'on veut qu'on
souffre encore et qu'on va souffrir
d'autres va s'ouvrir longtemps et il
faut vraiment alors là on est tous
responsables de l'image de nos quartiers
et on est tous responsables que l'image
que l'image change et ça aussi ça c'est
un message qu'il faut pas c'est qu'il
faut qu on porte tous habitants d'une
ville comme ça c'est qu'il faut qu'on
contribue à changer l'image de vous
quartier et surtout pas à rester dans
cette espèce de ambiance misérabilisme
qui a quand même été cette ambiance-là
de la politique de la ville oui on est
fiers d'habiter ici oui on est fiers de
grandir ici on est fier de réussir ise
mais faut que s'il n'y a pas de fierté
sur la territoire l'image ne changera
pas elle n'est pas que le fait des
médias elle est aussi le fait de cette
façon d'aborder notre propre avenir mais
ce que vous pensez que c'est pas plus
profond que ça parce que entre la
perception qu'on peut en avoir soi
de ces quartiers je peux vous dire que
la plupart d'ailleurs
contrairement ce que les gens pensent
ils sont très fiers de leur quartier il
le revendique
je vois moi qui suis rappeur je vois la
plupart des directs cesser leur maman en
fait leur quartier c'est quand ils
auront ils le revendiquent avec une
telle force et d'ailleurs ça crée même
des conflits avec d'autres quartiers
parfois tellement ils sont ils
revendiquent leur quartier mais c'est le
plus tôt plutôt le regard d d d d autres
et ça qu'elle comment on peut faire pour
que ça change là dessus alors moi j'ai
un peu simpliste le regard le regard des
autres change si ce regard est
accompagné d'une envie
il faut qu'en fait on nous en donne
envie il faut qu'on nous envie de notre
réussite là où rien n'était programmé
pour la réussite il faut qu'on nous
envie quand j'ai commencé la cité
éducative il ya un directeur
départemental de l'éducation nationale
de l'époque qui m'a dit mais attendez
madame are no 6 a réussi mais tout le
monde va vouloir venir chez vous vous
rendez compte vous n'arrivez pas
supporté j'ai dit mais le jour où ça
m'arrive un jour ça arrive à chanteloup
ma femme tenait là y aura plus de
l'image des quartiers abbas et ça je
pense qu'il faut donner envie il faut
que cette réussite à un moment donné
elles apparaissent au grand jour il faut
donner envie un petit bout quand même
sur votre métier on était avec pierre
cardo au début d'émission qui était
votre prédécesseur avec vous pour
conclure cette émission sur ce métier de
maire qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui vous
fait vous lever tous les jours à
10 ans parce que il ya assez pâle ce
n'est pas le métier le plus simple parmi
les maires je suppose d'être maire d'une
ville comme chante look mais alors c'est
un peu compliqué moi je veux
je crois en fait je suis pas sûr que
j'étais fait pour être mère mais je suis
sûr que j'étais fait pour être maire de
chanteloup
et c'est pas pareil et c'est pas parce
que dieu pierre cardo d'ailleurs c'est
un territoire qui prend aux tripes
sadr et or qui prend aux tripes d'abord
parce qu'il y avait il y avait une
discrimination et une inégalité
entre territoires et comporte un
champion qui était insupportable
vraiment insupportable et moi lutter
contre contre les inégalités c'est
pratiquement cg ça dans les tripes mais
c'est aussi parce que les habitants sont
sont vives dans l'affectif vivent dans
la relation affective dans l'envi de
ferran sens vide alors la relation
affective c'est je t'aime je t'aime pas
on est bien d'accord un c'est pas
toujours je t'aime mais au moins c'est
on allait enfin moi j'ai vraiment le
sentiment là que c'est pas la ville
c'est une succession de personnes cette
ville et quand on arrive à chanter c'est
comme la norme on pleure en arrivant et
un plan en repartant d'ailleurs par pas
on papa mais justement il ya un film qui
s'appelle les promesses de thomas
chritophe avec isabelle huppert et reda
kateb et qui s'est un peu inspiré de
vous et de votre directeur de cabinet
rémy en gros que je remercie parce que
ces cdt veut le véritable rédacteur en
chef de cette émission
et justement j'ai rencontré touba
christophe qui parle un peu de la façon
dont il s'est inspiré de votre couple si
je peux dire beaucoup pour les rôle
d'isabelle huppert et de réac à thèbes
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré catherine
sommes un peu au milieu du développent
du développement du vue du scénario et
et et j'avais déjà suivi j'avais déjà un
peu vu dans diverses affaires
intervention médiatique et donc voilà
j'avais envie de la rencontrer j'avais
envie aussi de rencontrer lé sous ce duo
puisque dans le film raconte un duo
entre isabelle huppert et son directeur
de cabinet reda kateb j'ai envie aussi
de rencontrer son directeur de cabinet
rémy en grand mais voilà elle avait elle
avait il y avait chez catherine
certaines des choses que j'imaginais un
peu chez le personnage et qui ont
participé un peu à l'enrichir mais oui
c'était c'était une rencontre assez
inspirante cas catherine arnould
probablement non pour pas mal de raisons
quelque chose de singulier chez elle que
je serai pas complètement expliquer mais
il met quelque chose aussi du une d'une
énergie une détermination
une franchise
quand je lui ai demandé ce qu'elle avait
fait comme métier avant d'être d'être
mère et qu'elle m'a dit qu'elle a été
médecin
j'ai d'ailleurs samassa m'a fait changer
le background des personnages du film et
je me suis dit oui non le personnage
comme comme katrina était médecin avant
mais j'imaginais catherine médecin
j'imaginais la manière dont elle
pourrait s'adresser à un patient comme
elle pourrait s'adresser à un citoyen
c'est à dire d'une manière d'une manière
claire d'une manière
pratique active
[Musique]
moi j'étais toujours être étonné dans
des villes de la taille de chant tout
même dans des villes plus grandes à quel
point en fait un maire est exposé aux
habitants en permanence quoi il ya des
permanences ont enfin quand je dis il ya
des permanences est à dire qu il ya d
iliad et créneau dans son emploi du
temps pour recevoir des habitants un
parent étudier leurs problèmes etc et
puis en plus c'est aussi un métier qu'on
arrête jamais dès qu'on marche surtout
quand on habite dans sa ville voilà on
est tout le temps exposé un petit peu au
problème paraît parfois des choses très
chaleureux des choses très très très
très positif mais cette espèce de
mélange permanent de voilà de vie qui
nous qui nous assaillent compte quand on
fait ce métier là voilà et il est assez
frappant est effectivement pour le film
catherine a été une des figures vraiment
vraiment inspirante pour compte pour
construire le personnage
[Musique]
c'est pas mal on parler de l'image
l'image de la merde de de chanteloup qui
devient isabelle huppert c'est quand
même bien pouvoir
non pour isabelle huppert wigna pourrir
la situation et
pourrait la capeb qui devient rêver en
grand
voilà
alors alors c'est une folie quand même
d'être maire d'une ville
pour avoir fait plusieurs campagnes avec
des candidats qui va les demandes et les
accompagner à des périodes quand vous
marchez dans la rue enfin je me demande
comment on fait pour garder son calme en
permanence pour avoir toujours l'énergie
de continuer à faire ça et et vous quels
seraient les prochaines étapes pour vous
au niveau national par exemple je
répondre à la question de la vente je la
préfère la question qui apparaît dans le
film isabelle huppert on lui proposa un
moment de devenir ministre d'ailleurs
mais alors moi je pense que
j'avais jamais rien programmé dans ma
vie et c'est ça va sauver puisque du
coup on n'a pas peur de l'avenir parce
qu'on n'a pas programmé c'est un peu
pierre cardo et quand je dis c'est un
peu c'est complètement pierre cardo qui
est venu me chercher et insister 1,6 et
insister lourdement et pour avoir compté
que ça dure et quelques années parce que
j'avais pas tout compris de ce que je
pouvais faire jaillir comment je
pourrais servir une fois que vous une
fois qu'on a compris après il ya eu
tellement de sujets alors comment garder
son calme d'aucuns diront que je ne
regarde pas tout le temps
et en plus je me revendique avec mes
colères mais voilà mes cicad j'ai le
droit je trouve que ça fait partie du
personnage j'essaye de le retenir parce
qu'on doit toujours essayer de se
retenir c'est un principe mais on a le
droit aussi de temps en temps trop c'est
trop on a le droit de temps en temps de
dire ça va passer vite c'est plutôt ça
qu'ils entendent de noms mais on a le
droit enfin on a le droit d'être entier
moi je considère les les habitants c'est
pareil à l'est mes interlocuteurs c'est
le culte ils ont leurs qualités leurs
défauts c'est un tout et donc il faut
prendre les gens avec dans l'ordre dans
leur totalité mais vous n'êtes pas posé
la question mais il ya une chose aussi
dans un territoire comme ça on est porté
poussé par les équipes on est poussé par
les associations on est poussé par les
habitants j'ai à vous dire vous allez le
voir tout au long de ces interviews on
est poussé par des équipes qui croient
terriblement qui savent à quoi ils
servent qu'ils savent fort courant elle
se lève le matin et des équipes qui se
qui se projette dans l'avenir et ça je
vais vous dire déjà ne jamais ne jamais
les décevoir et puis surtout avoir
toujours ce rôle de toujours les
entraîner c'est un espèce de c'est une
vie ensemble que nous avons il faut pas
qu'il y ait des éléments qui cède donc
en fait on est on est une espèce de
grandes familles qui partent qui avons
une énergie d'enfer pour faire évoluer
ce territoire et en plus être maire
c'est être concret c'est de voir comment
la la comment il peut y avoir une
amélioration dans un problématique
individuelle mais dans une problématique
collective aussi de voir comment le
territoire peut évoluer alors
l'urbanisme c'est pas tout mais
l'urbanisme il ya des choses qui se voit
de voir que de suivre les gamins et
devoirs à 15 ans qui sont venus alors
qu'à sept ans on était très inquiet pour
eux c'est ça le voir au quotidien
l'évolution des gens des habitants d'une
ville
ça c'est comme ça être médecin c'est la
même chose et pour être concret c'est
quoi la prochaine étape alors magic pad
prochaine étape parce que je pense que
je pense qu'être mais alors je vis une
période formidable aussi parce que je
travaille je suis au département des
yvelines et je suis au département des
yvelines sur les actions politiques de
la ville renouvellement urbain et
insertion et lui dit aussi donc activity
insertion et donc cesser complètement
complémentaire je m'enrichis de ce que
j'ai j'apprends ici pour faire pour
avoir une politique plus globale qui la
politique départementale mais qui est là
qui est juste l'échelon au dessus et je
pense que c'est des échelons qui me vont
bien
merci merci beaucoup qui a traîné redoux
rost merci je crois qu'on a essayé se
dévoila et
de ce qui se faisait en réalité dans
d'autres c'est dans cette ville de
chanteloup j'espère qu'on aura donné une
bonne image enfin je crois en tout cas
nous on a été assez par le développement
de l'investissement de tout ce qui
c'était très enrichissant c'est on a
l'impression que l'on re si tu l'être
humain au centre du débat et c'est ça le
plus important quand on considère
l'humain je pense qu'on fait les choses
autrement et on les fait certainement
mieux va très vite pour un nouveau
numéro c'était le premier de deux
tribunes merci encore à un rémy on rend
grâce à qui cette émission a peu à voir
voir le jour chez merci beaucoup et 4 et
d'un redoux
[Musique]